you know in uh
in brazil um some wonderful physicists
in brazil have just
done some fine-tuned measurements and
they have discovered that
two plus two actually equals 3.95
it doesn't equal 4 after all right this
is actually
just germaine because there was a recent
controversy about 2 plus 2 equals 5. i
don't know if you've heard of it
no okay so i think about one side we
could talk about that afterwards
no no no the other side was being
serious it was
it was because they were saying that the
way that math is set up
is western and it's not taking into
account other modes of knowing and there
are
possible worlds where two plus two could
equal five and in different
interpretations
which it's true i mean if you have
modulo something i'm sure you can make
two plus two equal five
or you round oh no you're gonna have
modular you're absolutely right
but it doesn't mean there may be
standard interpretation and there's
probably good rules of thumb
in in some sciences where you you're now
not talking
two plus two you're talking about two
somethings and two some things
so if you're talking about uh what is it
water a liter of water mixed with a
liter of alcohol
perhaps doesn't give you two liters of
liquid it gives you something like 1.9
liters of liquid because of the you know
the some atomic goings on
reduces the the volume of the whole
thing
you could you might conveniently talk
that way uh yeah because you're in the
lab and it's very constrained
but no two plus two equals four and more
generally
you know a little bit of arithmetic and
then i can become abstract and i can say
um any number m and any number
n if i add them together m
plus n it's going to equal n plus
m and everybody they think about that
for a minute and a half and say yeah
yeah right i
see it yes it's true and it has to be
true
that's an example of a mathematical
intuition okay
okay okay it's not empirical though um
math and ethics have been the two thorns
in the side of empiricism
okay um just for a second because i'm
trying to wrap my head around this when
you have n plus
when you have like a plus b equals b
plus a just so that it's clear for
should we not define that with the
addition being commutative
like you and then we make a model and
say that our numbers correspond to it
we we do but um
people's elementary experience with
arithmetic would lead them
in that very direction okay they've done
enough adding that they've been making
change they've been counting pebbles
who knows what um and after a while they
come to realize that whether they've
been told
that the community okay you're strictly
speaking about the intuition behind it
not proving it to be true that's right
uh because to the audience
that's really interesting we actually
assume it in
in the way that we define addition and
multiplication that they're doing
arithmetic
in any formal sense we typically start
out with something
known as the piano axioms okay and they
tell us
how to add how to multiply and they give
us a principle
called mathematical induction and then
everything in arithmetic
follows well i need to qualify that
almost everything in arithmetic follows
there is a problem about completeness
but never mind that
um and everybody's intuition if you've
been playing with arithmetic
for a while you'd say yeah this is the
truth this is how
addition works this is how
multiplication works okay let's not get
hung up on it let's assume
now we have the same thing in ethics